Just to recap we have a camera, which is observing
an object in three-dimensional space. We can
project the position of the object in 3D space
into the image plane where it has a coordinate
U, V. Assume that the camera is able to move
and it has translational velocity and rotational
velocity. The velocity of the point on the
image plane is related to the camera spatial
velocity by the image Jacobian.
We can demonstrate this principle very simply.
If I move my head to the right then the robot
and everything else in the world appears to
move to the left. If instead I rotate my head
towards the right then everything in the world
also tends to move to the left.
So there's an ambiguity between moving my
head; pure translation to the right and the
rotation of my head to the right. The visual
appearance is somewhat similar.
There are two important concepts that we need
to be aware of. The first issue is perceptibly.
In general as the camera moves, points on
the image plane move as well.
So there are some cases where with the camera
moving some points in the image plane will
not appear to move. In that case we say the
motion is imperceptible. Looking at the image
we are not able to tell whether the camera
is moving or not.
Another important issue is what we call ambiguity
and that is at sometimes quite different camera
velocities cause the same change in the image.
And we will give some concrete examples of
both of these effects shortly. Consider the
case where the camera is moving in the positive
Z direction we have this radiating pattern
of optical flow that we introduced earlier.
Let's consider we have an image plane point
right in the middle of the image plane. We
can see that the optical flow vectors get
larger as we move away from the centre. In
fact at the very centre there is no apparent
velocity. But, if I am heading directly towards
an object it doesn't appear to be moving to
the side or upwards or downwards; it's stays
exactly where it is.
This is the thing that I am going to hit if
I keep moving in the positive Z direction.
So if I just look at a point in the middle
of the image plane; it's not possible for
me to determine whether I am moving forwards
or not.
Another example of imperceptible motion is
the case where the camera is rotating around
its optical axis. So again if I consider a
point in the image plane there is no apparent
velocity at this particular point with the
camera rotating.
Clearly if I consider a point toward the edge
of the image there is a significant velocity
component due to the camera rotation. But,
in the centre of the image there is none and
I cannot tell by looking at a point there whether my camera is rotating around the optical axis or not.
Let's compute the visual Jacobian but, this
time we are going to do it about the point
which is in the centre of the image. And that is at coordinate 512, 512 that is the principle point.
That's where the optical axis pierces the
image plane and we can see that up here in
the parameters of the camera object.
We will compute the visual Jacobian at this
particular point, now let's take a look at
what happens when we move the camera and start
again with motion in the "X" direction. We
transpose that and we see again that this point moves at 160 pixels per second in the negative "U" direction.
Now let's see what happens if we move in the
"Z" direction and we see now that this particular
point is going to have a zero velocity.
So my camera is moving forward at a meter
per second and as far as that particular point,
its projection image plane; it's not moving
at all. And the same thing happens in the
case of rotation around the optical axis.
We see again, this particular point has got
zero motion on the image plane.
Motion ambiguity is an interesting thing.
If we look at the optical flow field due to
positive velocity in the "X' direction; we
see that all that all the optical flow vectors
point towards the left.
If I were to rotate the camera in a positive
direction around the "Y" axis we get the flow
field shown here on the right. And we can
see that they look quite similar. They are
certainly very similar in the middle rows
of the image, but we can see at the top and
the bottom of the image that for the camera
rotation case the optical flow vectors appear
to be slightly curved, they are not all parallel as they are in the case of pure velocity in the "X" direction.
There is some sort of ambiguity between translation
and rotation. If I translate the camera or
I rotate the camera we get somewhat similar
optical flow fields. Let's explore this in
a little bit more detail.
On the left we see the optical flow due to
pure camera translation. On the right hand
side we have the case for the camera rotating
around the "Y" axis. The top graph shows the
case when the camera has a lens with a large
focal length. This corresponds to a telephoto
or a zoom lens. And we see in this case that
the optical flow patterns are very, very similar
indeed. However, if we use a lens with a small
focal length that corresponds to a wide field
of view we see that the optical flow pattern
now is very, very different to the pattern
due to pure "X" translation. This ambiguity
in fact depends on the focal length of the
lens. We can explain this by looking in some detail at the structure of the image Jacobian matrix.
Consider the case where the camera has translation
velocity in the "X" direction. Then that velocity
multiplies this column of the image Jacobian.
The ambiguous case occurs with rotation around
the "Y" axis and omega "Y" multiplies this
column of Jacobian matrix.
For the case where "F" is very large a long
the focal length; then these two terms become
quite similar. So what happens in this case
because "F" is very large it dominates "U'
squared. So the result is effectively a constant.
It's no longer a function of "U" and the same
for the first column the corresponding term
it is not a function of "U". So these two
terms become similar functions.
If we look at the second row we can see that
it has "F", becomes very large and it is in
the denominator. This term will approach zero
and again becomes very similar to the corresponding
elements in the first column of the image
Jacobian matrix.
We can take an intuitive approach to this
problem. Here we have a very wide field of
view image of a cathedral that corresponds
through a very small focal length lens. And
here we see a narrow field of view image of
same cathedral and that corresponds to a large
focal length lens; a big zoom lens, a telephoto
lens if you'd like.
Now that large focal length lens corresponds
to the central part of this wide field of
view image. So in this central part of the
wide field of view image where the "U" and
"V" coordinates are small we get this motion
ambiguity. We can't tell whether the camera
is rotating or translating. But, even in the
periphery of the image where U and V are large,
the motion is not ambiguous at all. Camera
rotation and camera translation cause very,
very different optical flow phenomenon. This ambiguity is very definitely related to the focal length.
Clearly rotational motion and translational
motion are very, very different. But, what
we've just been saying is that using an image
sensor; just like our eye that it is not possible
for us to tell in general the difference between some rotational motions and some translational motions.
Surely this would be a showstopper for using
vision to control robots. And it is a bit
of a problem and one way to get around that
is to use a separate sensor to measure rotation.
So this is a picture of a rotational measurement
unit which has got gyroscope sensors in it
which can measure independently the rotation
of a robot and we can use this extra information
to disambiguate the information that we get
from our visual sensor.
But, what about us? We have our eyes and clearly
for us we can easily determine if we are rotating
or whether we are translating. Yes we can,
but to do that we also use inertial sensors.
We actually have rotational sensors in our
head. In our inner ear there are these three
semi-circular canals and they measure the
angular velocity of our head and we have three
sensors in our left ear and three sensors
in our right ear. And our brain fuses the
rotational information that comes from our
inner ear with our optical flow information
that comes from our eyes.
It is fused in our brain it gives us a very
unambiguous information about our motion whether
we're rotating or whether we are translating.